رصدت الجزيره لحظات اطلاق جيش الاحتلال
النار صوب عدد من الفلسطينيين كانوا في
انتظار دخول امدادات الطحين الى منطقه
دوار الكويت جنوب شرق مدينه غزه يذكر ان
اسرائيل تمنع لليوم التاسع على توالي دخول
اي مواد غذائيه
للمدينه الله بقول
ارجع
الان تتقدم اليه اليه
صوت وسط هذا القصف اليه الان تتقدم على
هؤلاء الفقراء الذين كما تشاهدون الان
يهربون بعد ان تقدمت واطلقت قذيفه بالقرب
منه الان صوت الاليه واضح تماما كما
تستمعون اليه وهؤلاء يهربون مهرولين بدلا
ان تاتي لهم المساعدات تتلقفه اليه
[موسيقى]
اس ايش مالك يا حاج متخب ايش فيه يا اخو
والله جاي لطحين وطخ علينا
اليهود والله العظيم جا ما احنا عارفين
ايش نعمل كيس الطحين عننا صار ب 1200 شيكل
يعني 300 دولار ابو 30 شيكل 300 شيكل
والله 1200 شيكل والله حرام واحنا جايين
للمساعدات اللي بتخش هذه على الله ان شاء
الله ناخذ لنا كيس ولا حاجه ان شاء الله
بس ما دخلش لهلق حاجه والله يا عمي ما دخل
حاجه وهنا زي ما انت شايفين قاعدين تحت
النار وعشان نطعم اولادنا ونطعم اهالينا
ونطعم اللي في الدار ايش نعمل الله يعين
الجميع الله يا رب يعين الجميع يا
رب يعني في هذا اليوم في المناطق الغربيه
وفي شارع الرشيد قصفت اسرائيل شاحنه
مساعدات وفي المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه غزه
تقصف هنا
النازحين